cette partie que tu considères toi-même
comme quelque chose de scandaleux comme
quelque chose de mauvais c'est peut-être
la meilleure partie qu'il y a en toi
c'est la seule qui te permet de
survivre Marie-Pierre donc né
Jean-Pierre oui connu aussi sous le nom
de Bambi lorsque vous étiez une artiste
connu reconnu du musical oui alors
pourquoi avoir attendu aujourd'hui
d'être retraité de éducation nationale
pour révéler votre passé et surtout
votre changement d'identité sexuelle
parce que d'abord je voulais vivre ma
vie de professeur tranquillement je ne
voulais pas qu'on sache quelle vie
j'avais vécu précédemment et je ça
aurait perturbé tout le monde peut-être
même on m'aurait demandé de me retirer
l'éducation nationale c'est pourquoi
j'ai attendu si longtemps avant de de
parler de moi j'ai voulu être discrète
discrète et vivre tranquille et ne pas
porter atteinte aux personnes qui qui
vivait avec moi parce que on porte
atteinte je crois aux personnes qui
vivent autour de soi quand on est un
petit peu éclaboussé par des scandales
et des candiratons et en ce qui me
concerne en plus c'était tout à fait
vrai ce qu'on disait était vrai donc je
voulais vivre tranquillement et que tous
mes amis en tout cas mes plus proches
vivent tranquille aussi Marie je dis
Marie parce que vous avez écrit un livre
qui s'appelle Marie parce que c'est joli
un livre qu'on ne trouve que sur
Internet toujours est-il que je voudrais
revenir Marie-Pierre à ce que vous
disiez à la fin du du reportage vous
disiez que vous aviez le sentiment
d'avoir évidemment vécu plusieurs vies
en une seule et qu'une 4rième hein
s'ouvrait devant vous j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir été plusieurs
personnes pas du tout j'ai toujours été
moi-même voilà l'impression que que j'ai
mais toujours depuis le plus jeune âge
en vous ressentant quand même fille ça
c'est important et comme s'il y avait
une erreur de la nature par rapport à
votre corps c'est comme ça que que je
les ressentis et quand j'étais dans mon
petit village de kabili il y avait
qu'une direction en Algérie qui se
présentait devant moi on m'avait
toujours dit tu es un garçon reste un
garçon et j'avais pas le choix et je
suis restée comme ça enfermé sur
moi-même seul dans ma chambre seul
dansant ma glace seul en prière à
demander des miracles que bien entendu
je n'obtenais pas
et et je voyais un mur de moi
c'est-à-dire que je n'ai jamais évoqué
cette question avec qui que ce soit ni
avec ma mère ou mon père
donc j'ai gardé ça très intérieurement
jusqu'à ce que je quitte
Alger pour Paris la seule solution pour
moi c'était tout simplement de
travailler dans un cabaret parce
qu'autrement je ne voyais pas comment
j'allais
pouvoir faire cette transgression bien
sûr puis que vous parlez de de quelque
chose de socialement abominable ah oui
donc c'est vous qui le définissez de la
sorte oui oui vous savez on se juge
soi-même comme comme les autres vous
jugent on est d'un certain milieu on a
les mêmes a priori on a les mêmes
jugements que tout le monde et jusqu'au
jour où je me suis dit cette partie que
tu considères toi-même comme quelque
chose de scandaleux comme quelque chose
de mauvais c'est peut-être la meilleure
partie qu'il y a en toi c'est la seule
qui te permet de survivre alorsi ce que
je trouve formidable dans votre parcours
he Marie piierre vous êtes devenu cette
artiste que on a vu cette femme
magnifique de musical sublime tout
allait bien et vous décidez après
l'opération de reprendre vos études et
de devenir professeur de lettre et là
vous repartez à zéro c'était très
difficile mais j'y étais j'avais un
stimulant extrême lequel lequel la peur
de vieillir ah c'est-à-dire que quand
vous êtes au cabaret c'est vous là
regardez professeur mag oui toujours
aussi magnifique et donc peur de
vieillir donc la peur de vieillir parce
que quand on a euh 33 ans euh et on se
dit c'est pas possible je vais pas
continuer comme ça à faire du
striptiesas à me montrer nu c'est-à-dire
que j'étais au carousel j'étais tête
d'affiche et je n'avais pas envie de
voir les les autres les petites jeunes
me prendre ma place parce qu'elles en
faisaient plus à coquetterie ah
exactement et l'idée m'est venue de de
reprendre mes études je me suis dit
parce que ma mère disait toujours dans
mon
enfance avec de l'instruction s'en sort
toujours quand je suis devenue
professeur et que je me suis mise à
enseigner c'est vrai que personne ne
croyait que ça pouvait arriver c'est
arrivé et dans des lycées difficiles
pendant 25 ans en vous taisant en
gardant ce secret pour vous qu'est-ce
que j'aurais dit j'étais un homme je
suis devenu une femme ça c'est faux
c'est vrai que c'est faux parce que un
homme est-ce que étais-je un homme à 100
% et suis-je une femme à 100 % donc ces
chosesl je préfère ne pas en parler les
laisser un petit peu dans le silence
plutôt que de raconter des histoires je
préfère laisser un petit peu les choses
comme ça encore que je crois que je je
dis tout ici je ne cache pas grand-chose
et vous auriez et vous auriez pu vous
faire renvoyer de l'éducation nationale
je crois que c'est moi qui qui aurait
été obligé de partir par imaginez qu'un
élève me dise un jour travelot parce
qu'il était en colère après moi
qu'est-ce que j'aurais dû faire demander
qu'on le mette à la porte non dans ces
conditions ça aurait été à moi de partir
et ça je le voulais pas ça ça aurait été
l'échec de ma vie vos anciens élèves se
sont manifestés autour de vous des des
enseignants qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit non
et les enseignants il y en a
quelquesuns un tout petit nombre qui est
resté très proche de moi qui m'ont dit
tu es marie-perre tu restes Marie Pierre
quant à mes élèves qui ne savaient rien
et qui ont découvert j'ai reçu des
quantités de messages parce que c'est
par internet c'est mon adresse internet
qui connaisse je n'ai pas reçu un seul
un seul message qui soit négatif tous
ont été ou presque tous enthousiastes
et les autres ont été charmants de quoi
vous êtes le plus fier aujourd'hui
Marie-Pierre l'important c'est d'être
fidèle à soi quand on juge en tout cas
que on n'a pas fait de crime qu'on a
essayé de s'affir mais pour son pour
pour son bien mais mon scandale c'est
justement
euh à l'intérieur d'une société hostile
qui me prédisait tous les mots possibles
et imaginables de mon vivant et après ma
mort c'était quand même c'est je dis que
le scandale c'est en fait de de d'avoir
mené toute ma vie sans scandale
justement je j'ai mené ma petite vie
tranquille c'est scandaleux tant
pis
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Inna
Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche